ELSE TO EXPLAIN BECAUSE GENNIFER
FLOWERS HAS A SHOCKING
REVELATION AND IT JOINS US NOW
FOR AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW.
HER FIRST IN SIX YEARS.
JENNIFER, IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I KNOW THIS MUST HAVE BEEN WILD
FOR YOU TO WATCH THIS OVER THE
LAST FEW DAYS, ALL OVER AGAIN.
FIRST, YOUR INITIAL REACTION TO
WATCHING HIM.
HE CLEARLY HAD THE BODY
LANGUAGE, ARMS CROSSED, AND HE
WAS VERY ANGRY THAT THIS
REPORTER ASKED HIM KIND OF SOME
FAIRLY LOGICAL QUESTIONS I WOULD
IMAGINE.
>> RIGHT.
WHILE MY FIRST IMPRESSION WAS HE
IS NOT AS GOOD OF A LIAR AS HE
IS TO BE, OR NOT ON HIS GAME
WHERE THAT IS CONCERNED.
AND I AM ADVOCATING THAT BILL BE
PROSECUTED FOR HIS SEX CRIMES
JUST LIKE HARVEY WEINSTEIN HAS
BEEN ARRESTED AND BILL COSBY IS
ABOUT TO BE SENTENCED.
WHY NOT A BILL CLINTON?
HE'S NERVOUS.
THAT'S WHY HE IS ACTING THAT
WAY, AND PROBABLY HAS SOME
HEALTH PROBLEMS AND IT HAS
AFFECTED HIS ABILITY TO RESPOND
AS WELL AS HE USED TO AND TELL
LIES AS GOOD AS HE IS TWO.
>> Laura: IF YOU ARE A YOUNG
WOMAN, 27 YEARS OLD WHEN HE
FIRST GOT INVOLVED WITH HIM.
HE WAS MARRIED AND THAT YOU WERE
NOT, AND YOU STARTED HAVING THIS
RELATIONSHIP.
AT SOME POINT, YOU HAVE NOW
DECIDED THAT IT BECAME A
NONCONSENSUAL HARASSMENT
RELATIONSHIP, WHICH DOESN'T
REALLY COMPORT WITH HOW YOU WERE
ORIGINALLY CLASSIFIED THIS.
SO NOW HOW ARE YOU ALL THESE
YEARS LATER CLAIMING THAT IT WAS
NONCONSENSUAL AT SOME POINT?
>> IT'S VERY INTERESTING BECAUSE
BACK IN 1977 WHEN I MET BILL, WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE LAWS TO PROTECT
US.
WE AS WOMEN, I WAS IN THE
WORKPLACE OF A MAN'S WORLD AND I
HAD TO DO THE BEST THAT I COULD.
WHEN I FIRST MET BILL CLINTON IT
WAS WHEN I WAS SENT OUT ON MY
FIRST STORY BY MYSELF AFTER MY
TRAINING WITH MY CAMERA MAN.
HE CAME OUT ON TO ME THAT NIGHT,
I TOLD HIM TO KNOCK IT OFF.
HE PROCEEDED TO CONTINUE TO COME
ONTO ME FOR THREE MONTHS BEFORE
I DECIDED THAT I WANTED TO HAVE
A RELATIONSHIP WITH HIM, WHICH
AT THAT POINT WAS CONSENSUAL.
IN TODAY'S STANDARDS, AND IN
HINDSIGHT, IT WAS DEFINITELY
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
I WAS A LITTLE BIT ASHAMED TO
ADMIT THAT BECAUSE IN A WAY, I
FELT GUILTY BECAUSE I WAS A
WILLING PARTICIPANT, AT A POINT.
SO I FELT GUILTY ABOUT SAYING
THAT I WAS SEXUALLY HARASSED IN
THE BEGINNING.
BUT IT DEFINITELY WAS,
ABSOLUTELY.
AND THEN -- >> Laura: WHEN HE
IS THEY WANT HIM PROSECUTED --
>> WHY NOT?
>> Laura: FOR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT, THAT'S A
CIVIL CASE.
FOR CRIMINAL PROSECUTION -- >>
HE JUANITA.
I'VE MET HER, SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL
PERSON.
LIKE HILLARY I WANTED TO BE IN
DENIAL, I WANTED DENY THESE
THINGS COULD HAPPEN BECAUSE I
FELT LIKE THAT WASN'T THE PERSON
THAT I HAD KNOWN.
BUT WHEN I MET HER THE FIRST
TIME AND REALIZE THAT SHE WAS A
VERY GENUINE PERSON AND HAD NO
REASON TO LIE ABOUT THAT, I HAD
TO COME TO TERMS WITH THE FACT
THAT HE WAS VERY CAPABLE AND IT
DID DO THAT.
WHY SHOULDN'T HE BE PROSECUTED
FOR RATE AS BILL COSBY HAS, AND
HARVEY WEINSTEIN?
WHY SHOULDN'T HE BE?
WHY DON'T THEY ARREST HILLARY AS
A COCONSPIRATOR BECAUSE SHE SHE
HAS ALLOWED HIM -- SHE HAS BEEN
THE PERSON THAT HAS LET HIM GO.
AND BE THE ENABLER THAT HAS LET
HIM GO AND DO WHAT HE HAS DONE
TO WOMEN.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, WE
REACHED OUT TO THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION COME TO
BILL CLINTON'S PERSONAL ATTORNEY
DAVID KENDALL ABOUT THIS STORY
AND ABOUT YOUR NEW ALLEGATIONS,
AND WE DID NOT GET A RESPONSE,
SO WE DID ATTEMPT TO DO THAT.
>> OF COURSE NOT.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY A
SNIPPET FROM BILL CLINTON, THIS
WAS ALSO FROM THE NEW YORK EVENT
LAST NIGHT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I SUPPORT THE "ME TOO"
MOVEMENT, AND I THINK IT'S LONG
OVERDUE.
I'VE ALWAYS TRIED TO IS
SUPPORTED IN THE POLICIES I'VE
ADVANCED.
>> Laura: WHILE HE SAYS HE
GENERALLY SUPPORTS THE MOVEMENT,
GENNIFER, AND HE WANTS PEOPLE TO
BELIEVE HIM AT THIS POINT.
>> THAT'S THE FOURTH BIGGEST
LIE, AND YOU KNOW SOME OF WHAT
THE OTHERS ARE.
HE WOULD SAY THAT, OF COURSE.
WHAT WOULD HE SAY THAT BUT THAT
HE WAS A IN SUPPORT OF IT.
I WOULD LIKE FOR THE "ME TOO"
MOVEMENT TO RECOGNIZE MYSELF AND
PAULA AND WANITA AND OTHER WOMEN
THAT MANY, MANY YEARS AGO HAVE
COME UP WITH CLAIMS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT BY
BILL CLINTON.
WE ARE THE "ME NOT" MOVEMENT IS
WHAT WE ARE.
>> Laura: WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
'S BEFORE THEY GET AWAY WITH
THINGS AND THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
INSTANCE OF THAT.
HE HASN'T BEEN HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Laura: I THINK THE "ME TOO"
MOVEMENT, LOTS OF GOOD STUFF
GOING ON BUT SADLY A LOT OF IT
IS POLITICIZED.
KIND OF LIKE WANTING A BROAD
RECORD, THEY DON'T COUNT.
PEOPLE LIKE KATHLEEN WILLEY,
THEY DON'T COUNT.
HOW ARE YOU DOING, BY THE WAY,
HOW ARE YOU DOING AFTER ALL
THESE YEARS?
YOU LOOK GREAT, BY THE WAY.
>> Gennifer: THANK YOU, AND
GOD BLESS YOU.
I LOVE YOU BY THE WAY.
I'M DOING FINE, I'M DOING A
REBOOT OF MY BOOK.
I LOST MY MOTHER IN JULY OF LAST
YEAR, SO THAT HAS BEEN A HUGE
THING TO OVERCOME.
BUT I'M DOING GOOD, THANKS FOR
ASKING.
AND THANKS FOR HAVING ME.